so we do have primary elections today a
three of the four scheduled primaries
are happening today despite what is
going on with coronavirus Arizona
Florida Illinois and Ohio were scheduled
to vote now Ohio Governor Mike DeWine
who's a Republican announced polls are
closed the Ohio primary is postponed and
tentatively for June although who on
earth knows at this point what our world
will look like in three months it's hard
to imagine what it'll even look like in
ten days if the current infection
numbers continue this is do or die for
Bernie I mean if Joe Biden picks up more
than an additional hundred delegate lead
on Bernie tonight
you know Bernie has a hypothetical path
right now although it's unlikely it's
already a longshot if Bernie Falls
another hundred delegates behind tonight
it's it's essentially done so we'll look
at national polling will look at
delegate counts we'll look at state
polls and figure out sort of what to
expect tonight in terms of the delegate
count going in it's a hundred and fifty
one delegate lead for Joseph R Biden Jr
894 to 743 we believed that tonight we
were going to have a total of five
hundred seventy seven delegates
available that's Arizona Florida
Illinois and Ohio Florida of course the
big prize with 219 delegates Ohio
postponing their primary so the hundred
and thirty six delegates out of Ohio
will be saved for another day so to
speak now in terms of the polling as you
know nationally Bernie Sanders has hit a
ceiling of about 36 percent and
nationally Joe Biden is leading the last
dozen or so polls most recently by as
much as 29 Bernie did manage to get 38%
in one in the latest economist YouGov
poll but the numbers looking very very
solid for the former vice president
looking state-by-state at polling in the
states that were scheduled to vote today
in Arizona Joe Biden averaging
+18 in florida joe biden averaging plus
39 Illinois has Biden at plus 29 and a
half and Ohio which again has postponed
their primaries as of now until sometime
in June who knows a Biden was up 22 and
a half I'm not even going to do delegate
estimates for what it'll look like at
the end of the night I mean I think we
all know that with these margins if the
margins hold it's a very bad night for
Bernie Sanders and a huge debate over
whether anybody should be voting at all
because of what you know we have on the
one hand and we'll get to it Donald from
yesterday saying officially for the
country you shouldn't have more than 10
people together you kids shouldn't be at
schools restaurants and bars should
close and we may have to continue some
version of this up until July or August
and then meanwhile Florida Illinois and
Arizona have huge crowds of people
presumably assuming people are showing
up to vote and we will we will find out
in just a few hours congregating and
doing all of the things Donald Trump
says they are not supposed to do there
was the idea that maybe the debate
between Bernie Sanders and Joe Biden on
Sunday night would change the numbers it
didn't we got we now have post debate
polls and the numbers are essentially
unchanged it was scheduled to be a
debate with an audience in Arizona
because of the virus the change was made
to do it in a studio with just the
candidates and three moderators with CNN
in Washington DC and again the you know
I think that there were a lot of people
emailing me expecting Biden to implode
unable to speak because of his supposed
dementia which has been a story being
pushed not only by people on the right
but also some people on the left yeah
and the problem is the expectation was
that Biden would so miserably implode
Biden just had to be coherent for the
debate and he was unlikely to really be
damaged and that's what happened you
know there there were some disagreements
disagreements about how to deal with the
virus there
I think Bernie's strongest moment during
the two-person debate on Sunday night
was when they started talking about
social security but again it didn't seem
like it was going to make a difference I
tweeted that I didn't think it was going
to make a difference we now have debate
but post debate polling and it has not
made a difference so far so we are going
to know very soon what at least in
Arizona Illinois and Florida Democratic
voters who choose to go have decided the
other idea that's been floated has been
because old folks are more at risk if
they get the virus
old folks may disproportionately stay
home which will hurt Biden and help
Bernie that was floated last week as
well now of course in a week a lot has
changed when it comes to the virus and
to people being told to stay home we'll
know within hours at this point I don't
know that it makes much sense to
speculate beyond these ideas we will
have a results live stream starting
tonight at 8:00 p.m. Eastern Time on
Twitch YouTube and Facebook live I hope
you'll join me we will take in the
results together in what are very very
strange times at this point quite
frankly I for me its but every morning I
wake up sometimes a few minutes before
my alarm sometimes with my alarm and
there's I I would call it a five-second
period it's probably more a fraction of
a second where I forget what's going on
with current coronavirus it feels normal
for just like a fraction of a second and
then I remember that that's not the case
and we've shifted around our entire
production to adjust to trying to stay
away from people and crowds I am you
know mostly just home this could go on
for months we don't know but there is
that split second in the morning where
it just feels normal
I'm wondering if other people are
experiencing that these are I think we
will all remember living through this
those that do and of course tragically
not everybody will those that live
through this will certainly remember
this for the rest of our lives
privacy calm is one of our sponsors and
they're giving you $5.00 just for using
their free service at privacy calm slash
Pakman privacy's of service i've been
you
for a while now I love it it saves me a
bunch of headaches it's completely free
and it's very quick to set up and here's
how it works
when you pay for something online or
over the phone instead of exposing your
real credit card number privacy lets you
generate virtual card numbers the
payments are withdrawn from your
checking account but your real card
number stays completely private and you
do it all with one click you can
autofill the card number in your web
browser on the phone you can create 12
virtual cards a month you can set
spending limits freeze them delete them
whenever you want I especially love it
for free trials where you need to give a
credit card number because I can destroy
the virtual card number as soon as I
give it to the company and I know I
won't be charged in the future if you're
ordering food over the phone why do I
need to give a restaurant my real card
number I don't have to companies don't
have to know who you are your real
credit card number is protected from the
data breaches that happen unfortunately
more often than we would like and it's
completely free they do have a paid
version with different tiers where you
can create more virtual credit card
numbers per month cash back rewards
extra security features but go ahead and
sign up for the free service it's a no
brainer companies can't charge you
unexpectedly you're protected from
identity theft it costs you nothing and
privacy is giving you $5.00 to spend
just for signing up when you go to
privacy calm slash Pakman